your waking world is shaped
by dreams
dreams
and nightmares that i create
and which i must control
so first for both of you
you like real you are the new dream what
is one element of the dreaming that
morpheus made that you would keep and
then how would you redesign it for
yourselves
wow
that is a
oh my goodness i keep fiddlers green i
mean firstly the first thing that's
that's tough is that
throughout the different issues of sound
man over the kind of the whole bear moth
that is the kind of the graphic novel as
a whole there are different
uh
designs and iterations of the dreaming
itself so like more physics castle looks
entirely different and different issues
so i might give that a bit of a you know
a bit of a polish
um oh what about you he's stolen mine
um i also love
fiddler's green oh it's just so lush and
beautiful and peaceful i just want to
like swish around in the grass
because you stole my other one
um maybe house of mysteries
spruce up
yeah it's quite it's quite depressing
around there
yeah fair enough i'd keep lucy in and i
would also up the amount of gargoyles i
mean okay i'm pretty sure
gargoyles in general or baby gargoyles
honestly i'll keep them both okay i
would like them both please
all right so tom for you specifically
now i was reading that you were trying
to meet morpheus in your dreams have you
had any success with that how have you
read that all right i feel like i only
said that about 10 minutes ago
what
this is how this works
it's amazing
technology sorry sorry
so did you actually make it happen
eventually well so the the truth is no
but having said that when i the day
that i got the part i did dream about
him um but i dreamt about him as opposed
to i it wasn't a kind of conscious
meeting between me and him i just he was
in my head um and that was a really
wonderful experience because i remember
waking up going
wow this is i'm playing morpheus and i
just dreamt about him and
it was very strange but then it is true
that that during the making of it
in a kind of jokey way but then slightly
more and more seriously i
i definitely started to try and take
control of my dreams um to not be
passive inside them to kind of to see if
i could you know as their creator make
things um
and then i did start to try and look for
him just to give me some tips on how to
play him what is the key to doing that
as someone who has no control over her
dreams and can't even remember them give
me your secrets
it's about really
i mean for me i can't speak for anybody
else um
[Music]
it's just about being really
the first thing you have to do is
realize you're dreaming i mean that
that's the first step which i have
become quite i've just become quite good
at it i've become quite good at going
okay this is a dream and then you almost
have to tell your whole body that it's a
dream and once you kind of start to be
conscious then you feel your body inside
the space and you can kind of start to
go okay i'm going to go left now
um
because because often in dreams we just
bear witness to something we're kind of
cameras as opposed to physical bodies
and it's about turning your camera into
you um and that takes a little bit of
thought but it is possible i've just
realized i've done that
god every day is a learning day i want
some of that please i need these uh i
need to be able to use these secrets and
actually access my own one of my
favorite parts of the show is the
dynamic between lucian and morpheus
she's so incredibly loyal to him but
also how do you figure out what kind of
i guess the guiding light should be in
terms of when he crosses the line and
she needs to step up and act is there
any specific anchor in that respect that
tells you in your head when she steps up
and says no
it's true to character
oh i think it's because it's for
protection
of both the dreaming and morpheus and
she wants to protect that so it's like
in life isn't it i mean i haven't got
kids but i imagine it's like having a
child you want them to express
themselves and be playful and maybe go
and play over there but once you see
that it's getting a bit dangerous and
that they might hurt themselves you have
to reign them in and pull them back and
say do you know something you can't do
that and i think that in that sense
that's a bit of what their relationship
is like not saying that he's a child but
it is that thing of very much going okay
i'm gonna speak up now because i don't
think this is good for you and it's born
out of love and respect
um and that's why i think that she does
say whoa whoa hold on
nightmares do not belong in the waking
world
oh it turns out i fit right in
dreams don't die
this series has been a long time coming
an adaptation on screen so after all
this time after all this work is there
any particular scene that wound up being
the most awe inspiring for you to see
come to life i think for me the thing
that was literally the most
awe-inspiring
was watching a pub
two people meeting in a pub and what
happened to that pub every 100 years and
the cumulative effect
of what our production designers what
our props guys what our costume people
what everybody
brought to that um
for essentially you know half an hour of
television
that takes you on this astounding
journey through time but is all about
friendship
and is all about loneliness
i look at that and i
it's like look if we never make any more
salmon if the whole thing if that was
all there ever was but we made that i'd
be
i'd be still the happiest
boy in
the sandbox it's a major major highlight
how about for you al well it's funny
that you chose a pub because i'm
choosing a diner so we go to hell and we
go to the dreaming and and we're
happiest in restaurants um
but only because it was the it was an
it's such an iconic issue of the comic
and it was so
terrifying not only because of its
subject matter but because i really
didn't know how we were going to do it
and so
the process of figuring that out and
casting it and because of kovid we ended
up having to shoot that right after the
first episode we built that diner we
were able to rehearse it like a play for
an entire day so that the actors got to
work on their characters and then we
shot it in sequence over the course of
the next 13 days with the actors all on
set all the time so it was which is it
never happens in tv and film ever so
that was something i had never
experienced before outside of the
theater and it was a thrill the entire
time oh incredibly effective all right
let's get into casting tom now so i was
doing my research and i heard you saw
something like 1500 audition tapes for
that role but you knew tom was the one
right from the beginning so what were
the qualities he had then that made him
stand out to you but then also maybe
just for fun what is the most out of
left field thing you saw someone do in
an audition tape for dream the most the
the left fieldest one for me was a guy
from i think eastern europe who they put
in
they sent to us not because the acting
was any good but because the guy looked
like a special effect he looked like
he'd been drawn he looked like he was
elongated
it was it was one of the most amazing
human faces and human physionomies i had
ever seen
and i would love
to you know if only the acting had been
as good as the strange glorious
weirdness of the guy's face it was
amazing
um
but yeah tom was i went back in my
emails
and lucinda seisner casting director
her first email to us
contained
four people
and tom was number three
and i remember
going oh good
there we go there's one
fabulous allen hadn't been sure that
we'd find one but there's one
in a week or so we'll have a dozen of
these
and then we'll have our shortlist and
then we'll get to choose but we found
one
he delivers every morpheus line
perfectly he's got the
the gravitas he's smart he's
he knows how to say this stuff almost
instinctively and none of these other
three are landing the dialogue
okay we'll be
you know this is great
and then
the next email
had you know another five and the next
email had another dozen and then
we're looking at them and
um
it the process kept going and then
covid happened you know we we just got
to the point of convincing everybody
that it was tom
and then cobot happened everything went
on pause and netflix were like just make
sure you've looked at everybody possible
so at that point we looked at about
another 800
more fierces around the world and
it was still
tom
number three it was him
um and
he embodies
so much he has
it's sort of hard to explain other than
you watch
three minutes of
[Music]
of
sandman and
thomas morpheus thomas dream
that's that's that's
something that you never have to worry
about again because
he is
so you find someone who you think is
perfect you have your wonderful source
material but what are some of your
earliest goals for the character going
into filming and how did those goals
evolve as you went through the
production process i mean we wanted
everybody to love him yes and we spent
some time trying to make him look comics
accurate which was just folly
um it taught us a lot and it taught us
that you know you can put a fright wig
on him you can put black contact lenses
in his eyes you can mess with them
digitally you can grow his fingernails
and in the end it just it just we lost
tom and so
we stripped everything away and and
what you're left with is tom sturridge
is the essence of morpheus and that we
felt supremely lucky and so the goal was
um for me
you know the sort of difference is
i got as the showrunner i had to really
track his emotional arc and his
psychology and
what his reactions are to the things
that are happening to him is and in the
comic we don't have the benefit of much
of that you narrate episode four he
narrates episode four but apart from
that you've got to start tracking his
thoughts and his feelings and why he
does the things he does and makes the
choices he makes and at first it was
sort of terrifying to know that that was
my responsibility along with tom
but then it became the best part so
we charted morpheus course internally
and and obviously through his behavior
as a as a trio and uh it was really
exciting because i learned a lot about
the character that i didn't know as a
comics fan
i thought about giving up
but i have a job to do when i do it
things have changed first question is
for both of you if death and desire
dreamed what would they dream about
[Music]
abstract a very
abstract extremely
i feel like i must have the
death of the darkest dreams i think her
her waking life would maybe be like some
sweet respite from from her dreams but
how could you not if that's your job i
don't know specifically what she would
dream about but i feel like they would
be dark
i think there would be a lot of
wetness and
and and pulsating
orgies in my cheeks
i am so sorry
but you know it's just like colorful and
and
a little sexual i'm picturing um that
music video liquor dreams from ohtown
you remember
that's what i'm thinking
here's another kind of like abstract
theory for you mason uh so
i feel like we get this with death a lot
in the show where we understand uh what
she understands about life compared to
dream but for desire what do you think
that they understand about life and
humanity that dream can't
well
a lot of the tension that comes between
the two of them i think derives from the
fact that they both have massive egos
and think that they are the most
important aspect of humanity and the
most important aspect of the universe
and because you know desire says it
themselves like there is no dreaming
without want and without need without
desire
and so it's it's kind of like a chicken
or the egg thing i think between the two
of them sort of run chasing each other
trying to prove to the other that you
know
they don't exist without each other and
so i i don't necessarily know
if they're really
what the answer to that necessarily is
except for the desire is
in their experience
one of the most if not the most powerful
and important aspects of the human
condition
because of how many
parts of humanity they control how much
falls under their realm from love to
need to want to sex
um
you know it is it is this
all-encompassing feeling that really
does inspire and propel us to do the
things that we do and to dream the
things that we dream and to and so i
that i think that's my best answer that
was a beautiful answer i love that uh so
kirby for you you have had a whole lot
of tv experience but there is really
nothing like sandman out there and
it was making me wonder of all of your
past shows which one would you say came
in handy the most as far as the
experience you had there that you could
apply to your work on sandman
interestingly enough actually a couple
of people have drawn parallels between
uh
the between death and
simone who i played in the good place i
think just because there is the idea of
death and the afterlife and things like
that but i do think that was probably
the role that helped most because um
one
simone had a lot of like very technical
jargon words and i think also so does
death in moments um i love tongue
twisters and then also i really
specifically one of the things that i
latched onto or that i was encouraged to
latch onto by mike shaw when approaching
simone was how much joy she found in the
world and how much joy she found in
learning and education and and that that
was why you know she was a scientist but
she found so much wonderment in that and
i think that's pretty similar to death
you know she she really does find joy in
the world and particularly in things
that other people may not find you
enjoying she finds a way to to fight to
delight in the smaller things
she's one of my favorite characters or
i'll rap with this one for you mason so
i mean desire is kind of like the
villain of the show but while playing
them are you able to view them as a
villain and i guess also to add on to
that a little bit how far
what was it like trying to figure out
how far to push it with the menacing
quality how big to go with something
like that
because it's delicious and i loved it
thank you yeah um you know in in in my
experience you desire is the hero of
their own story and and one of the first
things that neil told me you know in our
earlier meetings about the character was
that sandman could very easily be a
story that's told from desire's
perspective
and it would be a lot more fun and would
probably have a lot more sex in it and
that in that version of the story they
just keep brushing up against their
stuffy older brother who refuses to
change and refuses to acknowledge how
important they are to him and sort of
resents and blames them for everything
that's sort of gone wrong
in his previous you know past when it
comes to love and things that fall under
desires realm when in reality it's very
much so on dream so i think what's fun
about the character is that because the
sam man is told from his perspective
it's very easy for audiences to kind of
interpret desire as the the menacing
kind of
you know fun villain but for them
they're really just
kind of dealing with familial issues and
a lot of the reasons that they mess with
dreams because they know that dream can
handle it and the despair
is in need of something to do you know
despair is the only endless that has
ever died at this point in the story
like we we are meeting these two
characters and and desire is trying to
bring their sibling along
on some kind of journey whatever that is
in order to keep them alive as well so i
really tried my darndest to to give
audiences both sides of that character
so that people can eventually if this
you know gets if we get to expand all
the stories and tell the whole scope of
it they'll get to a point where they'll
really understand every single thing
that's happened between dream and desire
and why we meet them where they are in
season one
but for now it's kind of fun that people
just interpret me as this little nasty
minx
your eyes will tell me everything
every thought every feeling
[Music]
my creations do not walk amongst the
living killing mortals for pleasure
oh you don't think dreams can die
let's find out first question is for
both of you let's say you like as in
real you had rose's ability whose dream
would you choose to walk into and why
oh if i was rose or you were rose or
like you would really you had her
ability
so like in the real world oh my gosh i'd
have to go into some sort of political
espionage
yeah actually
that's true i
hm i want to know all the secrets i want
to know i wanna i wanna get into um to
nasa
i like that choice
yeah i was just thinking like i mean if
there was like
i can't think of anyone in particular
but like you know when there's like just
very powerful people or any dictators
where it's like what is going through
your head i would kind of want to know
you are using it for good i like this
i'm like put me in like michael crain's
brain so i could
like see what he dreams about dinosaurs
or something
all right so vanessa for you this is
like a huge first big project that you
booked right here so having gone through
the experience of making sandman season
one what advice would you give to
another up-and-coming actor out there
whose first project is something as
massive as this
um
i would say
um
take it in i would say believe in
yourself because it's easy to get
impostor syndrome especially if you book
something big like for the first time
um
i would say uh
learn to take care of yourself and pace
yourself and it's very
i mean there's a lot of glamour but like
it's still a job so allow yourself to
understand that you are still working
hard and you should take care of
yourself and allow yourself to um
just indulge in things sometimes you
know i mean it's easy to sometimes like
for me i kind of deprived myself at
times because i was just like oh yeah no
like you know it's so easy to undermine
what you're doing so i'd say don't do
that pace yourself take care of yourself
you're doing good that was like the
healthiest balance of a little bit of
everything i love it
all right boyd for you i obviously have
to ask about the corinthians eyes so
two-parter on that one what is something
about the effects work that's required
to do something like that that was a big
challenge for you to overcome but then
also what is something about all of that
that wound up being you know creatively
fulfilling in a way that surprised you i
loved the comic i loved everybody that
was involved in it that neil was going
to be so hands-on i just could not get
over the fact that
i don't have eyes
and so how is all the you know the
age-old thing of the the souls in the
eyes and alan was trying to reassure me
and
having the glasses and and all that it
just became this uh
rather than a hindrance it became this
sort of i guess you could say power that
i had and it was like being cloaked in
something so i really could transform
into to be something else because i know
that you couldn't see my eyes
and so that was
ended up being a wonderful thing i dug
that and how you carried yourself in the
role quite a bit
beyond the source material did you have
any other sources of inspiration for
what you wanted him to be in this
version like i don't know like a like a
folklore monster or another film and
television villain something like that
well yeah i mean inspiration comes from
all kinds of places i just started
seeing that he was this connoisseur
this uh almost like a sommelier of
eyeballs uh and so really embracing the
uh
the elegant and the um the delicacies
that uh that i had a palette for and i
just found this weird um culinary thing
that started happening for the
corinthian that i i just never expected
i just want to see a movie called the
sommelier of uh eyeballs now right right
you couldn't cut it with a knife it
would just keep bouncing off the plate
little hannibal vibes here i like it i
was wondering did you do any research
into lucid dreaming for this
that fascinates me oh yeah i mean not
for this actually
um not too much
about my own sleep schedule or sleep
life uh really changed because of the
show but in general i have looked a bit
into lucid dreaming um there was
actually a video that i listened to like
to try and do it and then like my leg
kicked and then i got creeped out so
i turned it off
but yeah it's a very fascinating thing
i'd love to do it one day
you